we're in Florida with Catherine's
forward Anthony duclair let's go for a
skate
who's the coolest celebrity in your DM
Terrell Owens is my boy heard you're a
pretty big Sneakerhead what's your
favorite pair of shoes that you own I
love my Travis Scott's little ones
Travis Scott got the best Nike apparel
out there if you had to pick a goal song
for yourself when you score what would
it be anything Kodak definitely
definitely helps for sure well there's a
Flo Rida concert before game three of a
favorite Flo Rida song what's up what's
that one popular song What A Night the
new one yeah yeah there you go that's
probably that one if you could play any
NHL player all time who would it be I
gotta go with the boat win Gretzky for
sure and last question favorite Miami
Heat player I don't go out Udonis Islam
obviously Jimmy Butler is uh is doing
his thing right now so those two for
sure thanks dude thank you